we'll hear from the president again this
morning after another round of talks
with the new leader of South Korea
president moon jae-in and his wife had
dinner with mr. Trump in the first lady
last night Margaret Brennan is at the
White House with the talks aimed at
South Korea's troublesome neighbor
Margaret good morning good morning well
the u.s. and South Korea want to
demonstrate that they are on the same
page as North Korea makes progress
towards a nuclear-tipped missile that
could hit the u.s. president Trump held
an evening strategy session with newly
elected South Korean president moon to
discuss the threat posed by
nuclear-armed North Korea I know you've
been discussing with our people some of
the complexities of North Korea and
trade and other things and we'll be
discussing them all but the Allies have
different views on how to deal with
Pyongyang president moon favors
diplomacy while mr. Trump is already
ratcheting up the pressure on Kim
jong-un's regime it's clear that we
can't repeat the same approach failed
approach of the past
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
described that threat as too immediate
to consider lengthy negotiations so the
president has directed us to to not do
that and to prepare a range of options
including a military option which nobody
wants to take Treasury secretary Stephen
minuchin announced new sanctions
Thursday against a Chinese bank that he
accused of laundering money for North
Korea the u.s. is hoping to make it too
costly for Kim jong-un to continue his
nuclear and missile programs and with
three Americans still being held in
North Korea Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson is considering banning travel
there by US citizens but White House
aides have torpedoed Tillerson picks for
top state department jobs including his
choice to leave the team of diplomats
handling North Korea out of a hundred
and eighty-eight State Department Post
requiring Senate confirmation only 23
ambassadors have been nominated and six
confirmed now that tension over delays
in hiring reached a boiling point last
Friday according to one aide Tillerson
had a quote spirited exchange
in a meeting with Jared Kushner and
chief of staff Reince Priebus about the
holdup now the secretary will be here at
the White House to participate in
president Trump's meeting with the South
Korean leader while they will deliver
Prostate mints they will not take any
questions
all right spirited exchange normally
those are really loud exchanges but
Margit let's let's talk about what's
happening next week this is a big week
with the President Vladimir Putin going
to meet face to face nose to nose eyes
eye at the g20 summit in Germany what
are you looking for what do you expect
well see that could be a spirited
exchange certainly given that us-russian
relations are at this Cold War era
low Russia sees this as an opportunity
to rebuild it's also potentially the
president's first chance to confront
Vladimir Putin about his country's
meddling in the 2016 election however
the president's national security
adviser HR McMaster says mr. Trump's
walking in with no agenda he said it'll
be quote whatever the president wants to
talk about so is he going to press
Russia to stop propping up Syrian
dictator Assad or is spend its military
interference in Ukraine we don't know
the closely-watched meaning though
happens Gail in the middle of this
ongoing FBI probe into Russian
interference in the election and Trump
campaign potential collusion with Russia
of course the president denies any role
in that Gail well there's certainly a
lot to discuss here thank you very much
Margaret